a 90-minute horror film based off of a
12-page Stephen King short story sure I
mean work for Children of the Corn
[Music]
ER did I say work for Children of the
Corn I meant sucked entirely though to
be fair Children of the Corn was like 40
pages or so the boogeyman is the newest
horror film that the studio either has
all the faith in the world of because
they're like look we're gonna come out
this week with spider-verse or they're
like look we're gonna try to bury this
under spider-verse and it is so the
trailer says an adaptation of the
Stephen King's short and he does have a
therapist and a boogeyman so there's
that it still feels like someone on the
production side was like we have the
scripts
Mr Stephen King you mind if we just say
it's based off of your short story and
then the conversation pretty much goes
down like if you're good at something
never do it for free
how much you want so this film largely
revolves around Sophie Thatcher and her
family her sister played by Vivian Lyra
Blair her father played by Chris Messina
and the boogeyman is latched on to their
family now at the beginning of this
movie I was like this is creepy I'm in
creepy Ambience good camera work great
sound design because good horror means
great sound design then from that
awesome opening to the end is a
consistent 90 minutes of diminishing
returns not that it's all bad because
it's not all bad at all what I liked
about this movie is for the first half
maybe two-thirds I felt that there was a
solid attempt at being a psychological
Thriller over horror I actually really
like and appreciate that they could have
gone for the Cheap Thrills but they
didn't they're like psychological Horror
family torment and pain it's a slow burn
absolutely but a slow burn does not mean
bad and then for the last act it's like
they were like do we say Slow Burn we
meant cliched horror movie nonsense that
the audience has seen a million times
before and that's a real bummer it's
like the last Act to this movie
diminishes the entire setup to it in
terms of tone and Vibe at least how I
was processing it because I said Slow
Burn that's how it felt at the time but
the difference between Slow Burn and
slow comes down to the payoff in the end
if you have great payoff that justifies
that Slow Burn will slow burn it remains
if you have cliche horror movie schlock
in the end will that Slow Burn is now
just slow and that's how this movie
ended up feeling it was a real shame not
that this movie didn't have positives
within that last act I thought the
creature design was interesting when you
could see it but this thing is the
Boogeyman it doesn't largely reside in
the shadows it can only survive in light
it's like you turn on the light it just
kind of disappears which means in the
last act when this thing is chasing them
it's chasing them but it's all dark in
this house and you can't see what's
chasing them you couldn't use the
situation to the advantage of the film
it's dark it's Broody something's in the
shadows stalking them sure and there are
moments of that in here absolutely but
having a Chase sequence with the lights
out you just can't see what's chasing
them so it feels like you're missing out
on the chase sequence it's like they had
the end the climax of this movie take
place with the lights on it's almost
like oh we established this thing can't
survive in light you can't even see it
in light all right we'll we'll have all
the lights off
doesn't really work but I'm not
rewriting this thing this writer strike
is coming man we gotta get this done I
thought the acting was great Sophie
Thatcher largely carries this film I
thought she did a great job now Vivian
Lyra Blair she played Little Princess
Leia in the Obi-Wan series regardless of
the flaws in the Obi-Wan series it was
very clear she's a really good actor and
for the sake of this film when you need
little kid looking scared out of her
mind whatever Boogeyman lurks in the
darkness she absolutely sells it and the
camera work that's going on when she is
there's Talent here there's something
great in this film it's just it's not
the film by The End by the end it just
walked out going all right I've seen
that 100 times before
didn't look like it was going that way
could have been something special kind
of feels like a kid who's sitting still
in church because they've been told it's
what they have to do and so they do but
by the end of them sitting still they do
it for 90 minutes or so maybe an hour of
90 minutes they feel the tension so much
they just have to run and scream and get
it out now that's what this movie felt
like maybe it'll be a better time if
you're drunk yeah
that's a part
all right so the boogeyman have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know are you gonna you're gonna
really watch this there's some spider
verse and this is the one you're
watching this week fair I won't tell you
how to spend your money but if you
haven't watched it what's a
disappointing horror film that started
out great and just ended up Matt
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]